♪♪♪
>>> EVERYONE KNOWS THE STORY OF
OUR LORD AND SAVIOR JESUS
CHRIST.
>> BUT THIS IS THE STORY --
>> OF ANOTHER MORE POWERFUL
CHRISTMAS SAVIOR.
♪ THE SNOW'S FALLING DOWN IT'S
CHRISTMAS TIME AGAIN ♪
♪ A WOMAN HAS TO GET A GIFT FOR
SOME GIRL AT WORK NAMED JEN ♪
♪ SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT JEN
LIKES AND SHE DOESN'T SUPER
CARE ♪
♪ SO SHE GOES INSIDE A CLOSET
JUST TO SEE WHAT CRAP'S IN
THERE ♪
♪ IN THE DARKNESS THERE'S A
LIGHT THEN SUDDENLY SHE SEES THE
CHRISTMAS SAVIOR'S HERE
TONIGHT ♪
♪ IT'S A CANDLE IT'S BEEN
SITTING BY A BIKE FOR A YEAR ♪
♪ FOR A YEAR ♪
♪ SHE TAKES THE CANDLE THE
CANDLE AND WRAPS IT UP FOR JEN
AND JUST SAYS HERE ♪
♪ THEN ONE DAY AFTER THIS IN
FOGGY LONDON TOWN ♪
♪ TWO ACQUAINTANCES ARE HAVING
CHEER ONE PUTS A PRESENT DOWN ♪
♪ THE OTHER SAYS WAIT WHAT I
MEAN I GOT YOU SOMETHING TOO ♪
♪ AND SHE RUMMAGES INSIDE HER
PURSE FOR SOME GARBAGE THAT WILL
DO ♪
♪ A HAND IT SETTLES ON SOMETHING
THAT SHE HAD JUST GOTTEN FROM
HER BOYFRIEND'S MOM ♪
♪ IT'S A CANDLE SAME CANDLE
REGIFTED ROUND THE WORLD IN JUST
ONE DAY ♪
♪ JUST ONE DAY ♪
♪ THANK YOU CANDLE THE ONE TRUE
CANDLE ♪
♪ THE CANDLE WE ALL GET THEN
GIVE AWAY ♪
♪ BUT HERE'S A WARNING WHEN YOU
GIVE A CANDLE THAT IS ALL THAT
SHE NEEDS ♪
♪ DON'T PAIR IT WITH THE LOTION
OR SOME LITTLE CREAM ♪
♪ A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK TWO
GIFTS ARE BETTER THAN ONE ♪
♪ BUT THAT JUST MAKES EACH GIFT
SEEM SMALLER AND DUMB ♪
♪ SO JUST GIVE THE CANDLE DON'T
OVERTHINK THE CANDLE ♪
♪ IT'S PASSED TO EVERY SINGLE
WOMAN AND MOST GAYS ♪
♪ WE ALL GET THE CANDLE WE ALL
GIVE THE CANDLE ♪
♪ THAT ALMOST NEW CANDLE ♪
♪ ENJOYED BY THE CANDLE IT'S THE
GIFT OF HAVING A GIFT TO GIVE
AWAY ♪
♪ THE GIFT OF HAVING A GIFT TO
GIVE AWAY ♪♪♪
>> THANK YOU, CANDLE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]